les monster high le jeu chasse aux
fantômes ou encore l' eee pad explorer
les grosses tendances de noël pour les
magasins pas question de manquer les
clients doivent trouver leur bonheur
sans délai novembre et décembre
enregistre 50 % du chiffre d'affaires
annuel pour les magasins de jouets soit
deux à trois fois plus de clients
ici à maurepas les camions approvisionne
tous les jours étude de marché en amont
et nouvel agencement boutique pour plus
de visibilité dans ce magasin de jouets
des clayes-sous-bois les rayons ont été
réhaussées pour accueillir plus de stock
entre 5000 et 6000 références en magasin
on a été dévalisé tant mieux mais on est
rare et a provisionné sur certaines
références notamment les stores you 2
donc des tablettes tactiles ou le jeu
chasse fantômes qui est le best-seller
sont les fêtes de fin d'année voilà on a
été ré en a été la sortie dont okley
c'est la centrale qui gère les
réapprovisionnements le flux
marchandises et tripler durant les fêtes
de fin d'année côté personnel trois
personnes supplémentaires ont été
recrutés pour une durée d'un mois
le but aiguille les clients le plus
efficacement possible
et lorsqu'on cherche un bakugan je
posais la question aux vendeurs et puis
m'a dirigé vers le rayon qu'il fallait
donc voilà et pour ceux qui n'ont pas
d'idées en fonction des lettres écrites
au père noël ouailles on n'a pas le
droit de faire autrement
chan